out of the darkness figures emerge
emaciated exhausted their eyes a mirror
of the horrors they've experienced
clutching their children or what's left
of their belongings they stagger ashore
the final steps almost too much for some
at least two dozen Ranga refugees are
said to have starved to death on board
after their boat failed to reach
Malaysia and drifted for weeks my mother
died in the boat four of us brothers and
sisters are still alive but one of my
brothers is missing the UN's refugee
agency has sent staff to help describing
the survivors as extremely malnourished
and dehydrated we suffered a loss we
were adrift for two months many of the
people died there were more than 500 of
us now there are only 400 the
Bangladeshi Coast Guard says it got a
tip-off about the boat finding us after
a three-day search off its southeastern
coast we entered Malaysian waters three
times but they didn't let us in many of
us died in the heat and sweat there were
too many on board of women and children
the Dhaka Tribune newspaper is reporting
the boat was turned back from Malaysian
waters because of coronavirus
restrictions the Coast Guard says it's
looking into whether the group was
fleeing Myanmar or the crowded refugee
camps in Bangladesh the UN says the
rahaga are the world's most persecuted
minority they're also the largest
stateless group denied citizenship by
Myanmar where many have lived for
centuries hundreds of thousands of
rahega have crossed the border into
Bangladesh since 2017 when Myanmar's
military launched a crackdown against
them those camps are locked down they
don't even have Internet services they
don't have adequate health services the
children can't go to school and so
people are making dangerous and perilous
voyage to try
to get to a better life in Malaysia
Malaysia is very reluctant to have more
people arrive at their borders and there
was a previous boat that came on April
5th where over two in a row Inga made it
- langkawi they're still in quarantine
and and there's concerns about what's
going to happen to them the UN has
offered to help move this group to
quarantine facilities and treat those
needing medical care or their immediate
future may be certain it's not the one
many here were hoping for
Alexia O'Brien al-jazeera